okay hi everyone so this week we are
going to be talking about the logic so
this is our last set of modules and
we're we're going to switch from
variable based models and start talking
about logic
so let's start with a question so let's
start with this question if x1 plus x2
is equal to 10 and x1 minus x2 is equal
to 4 what is x1 okay
so
think about this for a few seconds so
the way you would go about this is
you'll probably like use the thing that
you've used in algebra and then
basically like cancel out x2s together
and you would have like 2x1 equal to 14
divide 14 by 2 and you'll end up getting
seven right
another way of looking at this problem
is you can think of this as a factor
graph this is actually a factor graph
and we have these constraints and one
way of solving this is to to go and do
backtracking search and then actually
try to figure out the satisfying
assignment there but but the problem
there is like that might not be the most
efficient way of doing it and kind of
like the trick that you've learned in
algebra is is probably a more efficient
way of dealing with this question so
that is kind of like a motivation for
why we are talking about logic could we
do logical inferences in a way that
makes our lives much easier and then
allow us to talk about expressions much
more concisely and allow us to move
around symbols and and come up with
decisions come up with solutions based
on these sort of logical inferences so
have this have this example in your mind
throughout the lecture because we're
using similar type of ideas when we talk
about logic and then doing inference in
logic okay
so if you remember our course plan right
we started with machine learning and
then we talked about in general reflex
basement and reflex based models where
we have a low level of intelligence and
we started adding to to these levels of
intelligence thinking about state-based
models and then thinking about variable
based models and finally we are we are
at logic when we are talking about a
higher level of intelligence and
expressivity than when we think about
aiai systems and just taking a step back
and thinking about the paradigms that
we've used in this class we started
thinking about learning and modeling and
inference so the idea was we have some
sort of data from that data we're going
to learn a model we're going to learn
this representation and then we're going
to be able to do inference on that model
so once we have a model once we have an
mvp
once we have a search problem we can
basically ask questions and that's
inference right you can basically ask
questions and infer an answer and and
that allows us to think about different
types of inference algorithms okay
so examples of that is we talked about
search problems so when we have a search
problem like the objectives inference
problems that we're thinking about was
finding a minimum cost path or we were
talking about mdps so in mvps for
example or games you were thinking about
maximum value policies or or we looked
at csps or bayesian networks where we're
looking at basically like what is the
probability of some query conditioned on
some sort of evidence so so
these are some examples of inference
questions inference problems that we
have looked at
throughout the throughout the different
lectures and modules that we have seen
in in modeling so when you think about
modeling paradigms and we had when we
have state-based models we thought about
search problems mvps and games and and
we basically thought about these in
terms of states actions and and costs
right so those were kind of the main
core elements that would come in into
our modeling when we think when we were
thinking about state-based models and
applications of that were things of the
form of route finding or playing games
and then when we started thinking about
variable based models we started
defining this idea of variables and
factors and constraints between them and
then we talked about csps we talked
about bayesian networks markov networks
and applications of that were things
that that that was easier to think about
in terms of variables so we talked about
scheduling or tracking or medical
diagnosis where we have uh dependencies
between these different variables and
that was in variable based models so so
in this week what we want to do is we
want to talk about logic based models
and in logic based models
similar to state-based models and
variable-based models we're going to
define a few different types of logic
that we are going to be using so
specifically we are going to be talking
about prepositional logic and first
order logic and we're going to think in
terms of logical formulas and in
manipulating these logical formulas and
how we can infer new formulas from them
so specifically how we think about
inference rules
and what are some applications of logic
where logic shows up in a variety of
applications starting from theory
improving hardware and software
verification uh and also in general like
reasoning it's a core element of
reasoning in artificial intelligence
so historically if you think about logic
kind of like back like old ai was very
highly dependent on logic so logic was
dominant in ai like before 1990s so the
same sort of excitement the same sort of
hype that is around deep learning today
that same sort of hype was around logic
before 1990s and that was kind of like
the core of ai people were thinking
logic is going to give us really
understanding of artificial intelligence
and developing artificial intelligence
that could that could really achieve
things that humans can
but but that didn't really pan out and
the reason it didn't pan out was logic
had a few problems so so the first
problem was logic was deterministic
right and and it it couldn't really
handle uncertainty and that gave rise to
two things of the form of probabilistic
and friends and and in general
understanding probabilities and adding
uncertainty on top of logic or
developing models that can capture
uncertainty beyond logic
the second problem with logic based
models where they were very rule-based
and and they wouldn't allow like
fine-tuning based on data so so because
of that they they were very brittle so
if i have new data that comes in and
tells me something else then that
rule-based model is not going to be able
to capture that and it's really hard to
incorporate information coming from new
data and again that gives rise to
machine learning and this idea of
data-driven models and looking at data
and being able to be being able to learn
new models and being able to do in
france from that perspective okay
but the so so these are kind of like the
problem one and two are weaknesses of
logic but in general logic has some sort
of strength that some of our models
today like some some of the
state-of-the-art models so they don't
really have that and and i think there
is really an opportunity here to use
ideas from logic in some of the more
modern machine learning systems or some
of the more modern ai systems and the
strength of logic is expressivity so so
we're going to be talking about this
throughout this week in general but but
the nice thing that logic gives us is it
provides a compact way of expressing
models expressing representations that
that we wouldn't normally be able to get
so this compact representation can be
really powerful we could because we
could manipulate that that compact
representation and that could allow us
to to move in
to to be able to infer new ideas and for
new rules um and so on and in general
that expressivity is is a big strength
of logic and the reason that it is still
around and there is still excitement
around using it
all right so let me let me motivate
logic with an example so we've looked at
this example i think percy shown this
showed this example during the first
lecture where
our goal is we want to have a smart
personal assistant so let's say you're
sitting on the beach and this is after
the class and you're on vacation and
after covet and and we're sitting on a
beach and we have a personal assistant
and what we want to do is we want to ask
our personal assistant maybe it's siri
or maybe there's something fancier than
siri and we want to ask our personal
assistant a set of questions or maybe
maybe you want to tell it some
information maybe you want to inform it
about something or ask questions from it
okay so and and let's say we use natural
language so let's start with natural
language as a medium for talking to this
personal assistant okay so so let's look
at an example here so so this was the
system so let's say that this is my
system and i tell my system
all students like cs221 okay so
i'm telling it some information and then
my personal assistant says i learned
something okay
then i can say
um bob does not like
cs221 okay and then it would be like i
learned something and now based on this
knowledge that it has like let's call
that knowledge base so based on this
knowledge base that it has i can ask
this personal assistant questions i can
ask is
bob student
what should what should it answer
so if it actually does inference right
right it should it should answer no
right like if it if it has a set of
formulas and based on those it can infer
and it can reason then it should
actually be able to answer answer that
question underneath here there are a
bunch of formulas and and there are a
bunch of inference rules we are going to
be talking talking about that but we
could take a look at that and see what
are the formulas it has access to and
what are the things that it is unfair
and it is unfairing that that bob is not
a not a student here based on the things
that i've told it well this is kind of
uh this is an environment that we're
going to be talking about throughout uh
the lectures and other modules this week
all right so
let's go back here okay
so so in general when we think about
having this personal assistant where
we're using natural language or where
we're using where we're using logic the
idea is it should be able to digest
heterogeneous information and you should
also be able to reason deeply about that
information right it can't have just
shallow knowledge of that information it
should be able to inference it should be
able to connect these different pieces
of information and make logical
statements based on that makes logical
move space based on them okay so so why
should we use natural language that's a
good question why natural language uh or
like anything else okay
so natural language is kind of nice we
all like speaking natural language i'm
talking to you guys in natural language
it's a very nice medium to use when we
talk to personal assistants or when we
want to we're going to basically express
what what we would like to say so it's a
very rich medium for expressing what we
want
um and and because it is rich we can say
things like i don't know a dime is
better than a nickel and and we can say
things like a nickel is better than a
penny
and and based on that we could be able
to make expressions we could make
logical statements based on that and say
therefore a dime is better than a penny
which which makes sense
but the problem with natural language is
um it's also a little bit slippery like
um i can start with something that says
a penny is better than nothing that's
okay and then i would have another
statement that just says nothing is
better than world peace and that's
perfectly fine and putting these two
together i can come up with a logical
like
kind of a statement based on based on
what i've seen that a penny is better
than world peace which sounds a little
bit weird and not not correct and not
the thing that i actually wanted okay
so even though natural language is
pretty rich
when we are thinking about logical
statements and making logical uh logical
inference
here and following like inference rules
it feels like natural language is a
little bit slippery and you might want
to have access to some other type of
language so this language like when we
talk about language it doesn't need to
be natural language right language is
just a mechanism for expressing things
it's just a way of expressing okay so um
natural language is an example of a
language that allows us to express
things it's kind of informal
we also have programming languages that
those are kind of formal like we have
like python or c spots
in addition to this we can have logical
languages and the nice thing about
logical languages is that they're formal
and we can think about the relationship
between them and formal formal
connections between them but the other
nice thing about logical languages is
they're actually closer to natural
language than let's say programming
languages because they're declarative so
so there is like actually a connection
between natural language and logical
languages and in one of the later
modules we're actually going to talk
about how we can write expressions in
first order logic if we have a natural
language statement so
so in this lecture this week we are
going to be talking about two types of
logical languages propositional logic
and first order logic
all right so what what is the goal of a
logical language so the goal here is to
be able to represent knowledge right you
want to be able to represent knowledge
about the world but that is not the only
goal in addition to that you want to be
able to reason about that knowledge
right it's not just about representing
it's about how we can move how we can
make logical statements and how we can
we can run inference rules and how we
can make new statements and reason about
them so so an example is if i tell you
guys it's it's raining and it is wet you
should be able to reason about that and
should be able to figure out that well
it is raining and right are you telling
me raining and wet so so it is it is
definitely like both of those statements
are true and you should be able to
reason about that and that is the goal
of um of a logical language
and and when we think about logic
uh we have kind of three main
ingredients for logic i'm going to go
into these details a little bit more in
our first module but let me just give
you a quick overview so we're going to
have syntax
and syntax basically is tells us like
are the symbols of of that language so
so basically it defines a set of valid
formulas so so syntax here for example
in a logical formula in propositional
logic syntax could be rain and wet okay
so when i write rain and red here this
ends in the syntax land doesn't have any
meanings it's just a symbol it's just
like this shape okay and then reign into
it they don't have any any meanings
they're just symbols okay so so when
you're talking about syntax you're
really talking about the symbols that
are building blocks of language but
symbols are alone like syntax alone is
not going to be able to define a
language in addition to syntax what we
need is semantics we actually need to
give meaning to the syntax so for each
one of these formulas we need to be able
to specify a meaning or we specify it as
a meaning has a very very precise
meaning to it so so meaning corresponds
to an assignment a configuration of the
role like a setting in the world that
that corresponds to that formula that
corresponds to that syntactical formula
so for example in the case of rain and
wit it actually corresponds to specific
meaning where rain takes value one and
what takes value one and and this is
like a specific model a specific world
where we live in and and in this world
rain and red has this particular meaning
okay so so the main ingredients of logic
are first of syntax and semantics and
once we have syntax and semantics then
we can talk about inference rules we can
actually talk about what can we infer
not now that we have a set of formulas
or we have a set of knowledge about the
world so so given that we have a formula
f could we infer could could we derive a
new formula g could we figure out like
if g is true or not based on f for
example like if you tell me rain and wet
as a formula from that i can derive rain
is also true right because it's got to
be rain and do it so from from that i
should be able to derive right right and
then that's what we are going to spend
quite a bit of time this week because
what are the inference rules that we can
play around with and and how do they
apply to different types of logic okay
so three ingredients syntax semantics
and inference rules
all right so let me just um make a
bigger point for this difference between
syntax and semantics because the
difference might be a little subtle so
so again if you think about syntax
syntax is talking about the valid
expressions that are in your language
it's basically talking about the symbols
right the things that are valid to say
in the like the the the
the symbols that are valid to write in
this in this language semantics is about
what the expressions means means so so
let me give you an example here so let's
say if you're looking at 2 plus 3 versus
3 plus 2 okay 2 plus 3 and 3 plus 2 have
different syntax they're not the same
they don't look the same if i have no
idea what two means or plus means or
three means right two plus three has
nothing to do with three plus two they
have two very different syntax but they
have the same semantics right if i know
what plus means and what two means and
what three means and if i know what two
plus three is five and three plus two is
five then they have the same meaning
they have they have they have the same
the same semantics so different syntax
but similar the same semantics on the
other hand we can have settings where we
have the same syntax things look the
same but they have different meanings
for example you can look at three over
two in python 2.7 versus python three
and in that case it's like it looks the
same three looks the same the divide
looks the same two looks the same so
syntactically these two are exactly the
same thing but semantically they have
different meanings they actually
correspond to different values right
when you're doing this in python 2.7 or
python 3. okay so so again we have two
expressions that have the same syntax in
this case but they have different
meanings and different semantics so
syntax and semantics are two different
things both of them are needed to define
a logical language
and i want to kind of like end with this
this view uh that and this diagram that
i'm gonna come back to and explain it in
in a bit more detail in kind of future
modules so so the idea is we have two
worlds here we have on the left we have
uh syntax syntax land and on the right
we have semantics land okay so in syntax
land we have formula so i'm going to use
these rectangles to define to kind of
like represent formulas these are
different formulas that i can write like
rain and wet and each one of these
formulas have a meaning in in this
semantics line okay so each formula has
a meaning in the semantics and and
that's called models here
and what our goal is throughout the
lecture is to come up with inference
like first define syntax and semantics
for different types of logics and then
after that come up with inference rules
that allow us to manipulate these
formulas these compact formulas that are
kind of like nice and expressive and
manipulate them and come up with new
formulas and fair new formulas that that
have meanings that that are also
entailing the meanings of our current
formulas so more on this later if this
is confusing i will talk about this in
more details in a few in a few modules
okay
just to give you a quick overview of
different types of logics you are being
we will be talking about there are
different types of logics and and in the
order of a disorder
they're they're kind of like increasing
in the order of increasing of
expressivity so uh and in this uh this
week we are going to be talking about uh
the bolded ones so we will be talking
about propositional logic and
specifically propositional logic a
subset of it that only has these things
that are called horn clauses so we'll
talk about what those are
and we will also talk about first order
logic so first order logic only with
horn clauses and just generally first
order logic there are other types of
logic that we're not discussing in this
class second order logic temporal logic
and they're actually quite useful and in
a variety of fields in programming
languages and robotics and formal
methods um and yeah like if you're
interested in any of these we can chat
about it offline one other point i want
to make is as we increase like the level
of expressivity of logic here like as
you go down in this list like
expressivity of these logics are is
going higher and higher but the thing
that you're losing on is computational
efficiency so if you want to run
inference rules it's going to become
much more difficult if you're running it
on first order logic as opposed to
propositional logic so so there is a
trade-off between computational
efficiency and expressivity of that
logical language
all right so with that this is the
roadmap for this week's lecture so
lectures so
we're going to start with kind of like
modeling and by modeling here i mean
what i mean is defining the syntax and
semantics of logic so so we're going to
talk about propositional logic and the
syntax of that then we are going to talk
about the semantics of propositional
logic at that point we're going to be
switching to inference and discussing
inference rules and in general we're
going to be talking about two main
inference rules modus ponens is one and
the other one is resolution so so we're
going to talk about under propositional
logic how do we do modus ponens how do
we do resolution at that point we're
going to switch back to to a higher
level of expressivity in terms of our
models we're going to talk about first
order logic after that again syntax and
semantics of first order logic and then
after that we're going to talk about
modus ponens again an inference rule for
first order logic and we have an
optional
module at the end which is about
resolution for first order logic this
gets a little bit hairy but if you're
interested you can kind of look at look
at this
and how resolution gets applied to first
order logic and then we're not talking
about learning during this week in
general learning more recently has been
applied uh to to to kind of logical
formula specifically in the area of
formal methods
people have been thinking about learning
logical formulas from data from
demonstrations
but that's outside the scope of this
class so we will not be talking about
that
you